on parle moins de l'afghanistan
aujourd'hui mais un nombre de victimes
civiles continuent d'augmenter en six
mois plus de 1500 civils ont été tués et
trois mille trois cents blessés
c'est un pour cent de plus qu'à pareille
date l'an dernier qui a été l'année la
plus meurtrière pour les afghans depuis
que l'onu a commencé à compiler ces
données en 2009 et un plus grand nombre
de ces victimes sont des femmes et des
enfants
les insurgés talibans sont toujours
responsables de la grande majorité des
pertes civiles mais c'est le nombre qui
est attribuable aux forces armées
afghanes qui a le plus augmenté
rappelons que la mission de combat de
l'otan s'est terminée en décembre
dernier les troupes canadiennes elles se
sont retirés en mars 2014